allies meet at The Summit in villages
later on allies will agree to have a
more ambitious defense investment pledge
where we regard two percent of GDP for
defense not as a ceiling but that's the
floor a minimum that we need to spend in
a more dangerous World on our security
and then
we will also meet with our Asia Pacific
Partners New Zealand
Australia Japan and South Korea
security is not a regional Securities
Global what happens in Europe matters
for the indo-pacific for Asia and what
happens in Asia matters for Europe and
the war in Ukraine really demonstrate
start with all this Global ramifications
and also when we see that China and
Russia are coming more and more closely
that they stand together work to get
together it makes it even more obvious
that we need to stand together with
our partners in the Pacific
to take your questions
foreign
military buildup also in the north close
to Finland to Norway and this has taken
place over many years in the collapse in
Islam in the Arctic
and we have not only the senior Russian
military Builder but also seen that
Russia is uh willing and President Putin
is willing to use military force against
neighbors Georgia in 2008 then a Crimea
in 2014 and then the full-fledged
invasion of Ukraine last year so this is
part of a pattern and that's exactly why
we have strengthened NATO our Readiness
our presence in the eastern part of the
Lions and why NATO allies are investing
more also in new modern capabilities and
it was actually the invasion of Ukraine
last year that led to the decision by
Finland and Sweden to apply for a NATO
membership
and it just demonstrates that when
President Putin had as an uh declared
goal of the invasion of Ukraine to get
less NATO he wanted less NATO along his
borders he wanted to close NATO store no
more NATO membership for any uh more
countries in Europe is getting exactly
the opposite he's getting more troops
more redness and more forces Lancey and
Air
in the eastern part of the alliance and
he's getting more members Sweden today
and soon also
Finland today and soon also Sweden will
become a full-fledged member of the
alliance then we are constantly
assessing our posture our presence we
have more exercises we are more presence
on also in the Nordic area but but again
this is something which is part of a
pattern that NATO has already responded
to
Mr stoneberg what does this mean
personally to you is this sort of an
emotional highlight for your term and
secondly can you really celebrate when
Sweden is not ready to to join yet
so I'm glad and I'm proud to be the
Secretary General
um that can welcome Finland as a
full-fledged member of the alliance
this is important for NATO it's
important for Finland it's important at
least for the Nordic region and the
Baltic region you can just look at the
map and you stand how important Finland
is for the security in the Nordic and
the Baltic region and then also of
course Finland brings high-end
capabilities
substantial forces
and also the advanced defense industry
into the alliance
but personally I'm also not because I'm
from Norway I've worked with Finland and
Finnish politicians and leaders for many
many years and of course not so many
years ago we thought it was Unthinkable
that Finland would become a member now
they are a full-fledged member of our
alliance and that is truly historic and
uh and something that demonstrates that
Finland is a servant independent country
they make their own decisions and NATO
is an alliance of democracies with an
open door to democratic Seven Nations as
as Finland
will the security guarantees need to now
apply 100 to Finland and what will the
difference between killings
well what happens today is that Finland
becomes a full-fledged member of the
alliance and that means of course that
they will now participate fully as a
member in all NATO meetings activities
military structures command structure
and all parts of NATO uh civilian and
and Military structures but of course
most importantly is that by becoming a
member
Finland will get an iron CAD security
guarantee Article 5 our collected
defense Clause One for All For One well
now from today apply for Finland then of
course this
is something that
uh Builds on what has happened over the
last year because when NATO allies when
the heads of state and government at The
Summit in Madrid in June austere decided
to invite Finland Sweden then both
Finland and Sweden came in a much
stronger and much better position
towards NATO than before
so also Sweden which is not yet a
full-fledged member uh it's in a very
close to a much better position as an
invitee they participate in NATO
meetings they are integrating into NATO
structures we are developing
KPD targets taking account for also
Sweden when we do defense planning so so
Sweden is also very close to Nato but of
course they haven't that final
ratification by all allies and therefore
another full-fledged member that was
hard on Sweden and you're actually also
had a question about Sweden is that of
course
it is a great day to have Finland as a
member
but we will ensure that auto also Sweden
will become a full member and we have to
remember that all allies agreed to
invite them and all allies have signed
the accession protocol uh what remains
when it comes to Sweden is the
ratification in two parliaments I'm
confident that will happen uh I met with
President aduan so weaksu has also spoke
with him on the phone uh uh recently and
and and and and and we agreed uh of
course first of all to ensure that
Finland becomes a full member that the
accession process is now finalized for
Finland but we also agreed to restart
the process the meetings or the
permanent mechanism the meetings of
Finland Sweden and and turkey to ensure
us that we can make progress on the
ratification of uh of Sweden so Sweden
is in a much better place now than
before they applied and we will continue
to work hard to ensure that we can
finalize the ratification for the social
[Music]
um
it is finished decision whether they
would like to have uh any uh there will
be no NATO troops in Finland without the
consent of uh of uh of Finland
um and of course what we have in many
countries is that we have exercises we
have a naval and uh and uh an air
presence and so on but we don't have
permanent basis and this has not been an
issue so far in our discussions with uh
with Finland
um
well um
the reality is that this is a result of
present Putin's
War regression against Ukraine
and of course Finland also has in
history that tells them about the
brutality uh that a war can afflict on
the country like the now see in Ukraine
and I like Finance all during the the
winter war in 1930 in 1914.
um and therefore when they saw that
President Putin didn't not only threaten
Ukraine but actually it threatened every
nation in Europe that wanted to make
their own decisions on joining it or not
then finna decided to to join the
alliance